العدالة هي كلمة حاسمة للغاية لا يمكن أن يتحقق السلام
أبدًا من خلال هذه الإملاءات
والتنمر
، أعني أن الأمم لا يمكن أن تتعرض للتخويف مثل
هذا من قبل رئيس أمريكي
لا يعرف الكثير عن الشعب الفلسطيني
يعتقد أننا نعيش على الصدقات في
الواقع نحن من أغنى  في
المنطقة لدينا الموارد البشرية
لدينا الموارد الطبيعية ولكن
يتم سرقة مواردنا من قبل الرجل
الذي يقف بجانبه أو يقف
بجانبه
بنيامين نتنياهو
وحكومته وبالمناسبة وجدنا أنفسنا
التمويل الدولي صغير
جزء صغير من ميزانيتنا ،
لسنا بحاجة إلى أمواله ، وإذا كان يعتقد أن
الرئيس من هذا القبيل في الواقع يمكنه
رشوتنا ويمكنه شراء حقوقنا ، فنحن
لسنا معروضين للبيع ، قلنا لهم هذا
مباشرة نقول لهم هذا الآن  إن السبيل الوحيد
لتحقيق السلام هو
إعمال الحقوق
الفلسطينية ، وهذه الحقوق كرسها
القانون الدولي حل الدولتين ،
سواء لم يكن أبدًا مطلبًا فلسطينيًا.
كان مطلبًا دوليًا
وقد قدمنا هذا الامتياز إلى ال
جتمع الدولي واليوم أع
قد أن الأمر متروك للمجتمع الدولي لل
فاع عن نظ
مه الخاص ، وأعتقد أننا ال
لسطينيون سنبقى حيث نح
سنربي أطفالنا على  أعلى
المعايير التي نتمتع بالمرونة سوف
نثابر عليها رأينا العديد من
الإمبراطوريات تأتي وتذهب.
المستقبل وأقول لكم
اليوم أن إسرائيل قد دخلت في
نظام الفصل العنصري الكامل والأمر يتعلق
بالنظام الدولي